do you know peter parker who's
spider-man yes is that him no
can you please explain what is going on
after i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors from every universe
multiverse is real
i need you to capture them before they
destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna
need some help you guys ready let's
catch some multiverse men
spider-man your way home what was your
name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop them
well you're thinking i'm about to do
something that could break the universe
i know you run it by us
we need to send them back
you're not gonna take this away from me
you're flying out into the darkness to
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting spider-man i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another way there isn't
spiderman no way home december 17th
you're not peter parker i am so confused
right now
that spell that you bought started
pulling in visitors from every
the universe is real
[Applause]
they all die fighting spiderman there
has to be another way there isn't
they're a danger to our universe
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
spiderman no way home in theaters
december 17th
you